in case you missed it AG T's latest
golden buzzer is one you're gonna want
to see plus Lady Gaga's a stars born
trailer is here while the queens of
oceans eight shut down the red carpet at
their New York premiere hello friends
I'm Danny direct oh and it is Wednesday
and I've got some hump day treats for
you it's the clips everyone is talking
about that I can't get enough of now if
you didn't catch last night's America's
Got Talent then you missed Michael
Ketterer a pediatric mental health nurse
in Orange County California husband and
father of six kids
he touched America with his story and
wowed the judges with his voice you
won't believe what this guy sounds like
take a look
[Music]
to love somebody to love somebody the
way that I love
[Music]
all the way
[Music]
I know and the crazy part about this is
Michael was so nervous and unassuming
that when he's saying it was game over
for me plus he didn't have the sweetest
story he told the judges his six kids
came from foster homes and quote when
you're surviving
you can't dream and he wanted to inspire
his six kids to chase after their dreams
well listen dad's dream earned him the
golden buzzer from fellow Papa Simon
Cowell actions speak louder
[Applause]
[Music]
chills every time guys that damn golden
buzzer right after his audition aired
Michael tweeted I'm so thankful for all
the support and love that I'm receiving
for my family friends and people that
have never met before
my family and I are undone and are so
thankful to God for this amazing
opportunity
I mean holler at me in the comments if
you guys love Michael Keller or two and
we will see him at the live shows later
this summer now in the meantime here is
another musical moment sure to give you
guys the chills the first trailer to a
star is born with Lady gaga and Bradley
Cooper just dropped and I'm going gaga
for it
it's her first feature film and from the
looks of it they're about to rock our
socks off
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
with
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
anyone else think Gaga is going for that
Oscar gold now the movie is directed by
Cooper himself and I can't wait for it
but gonna have to because it's not out
until October thankfully though we've
got oceans eight that summer movies
coming out so so so so soon and last
night the all-female cast put in work
work work work at the premiere
look at this Kate aquafina Sarah and
Sandra Mindy Helena Ariana did not come
to play there glamp to the ninth there
or the eighths anyway it's the first
time RiRi has done any press for the
movie and et turned the tables on her on
the red carpet Tuesday after she asked
this pointed question to her cast mates
I want to know
who has actually stolen something in
their life miss Ariana yeah that is
Rihanna I would say yes well I was young
I was young and I didn't know any better
all of the ladies absolutely loved your
question with that you gave to us about
who stole something in their lives Sarah
did it velvet bodysuit and stole books
Kate said she stole bread I don't know
so they wanted to turn it back on you
and ask you the same Hey I stole Chinese
food how did you steal Chinese food it's
a long story
can't we just go to this do we have to
steal stuff yes
[Music]
who else is excited for that movie we
are well into summer movie season and
has so many more to come in fact don't
forget we have our summer movie preview
of on et online but moving on to
Rihanna's former fleeing Drake who will
likely won't be who likely won't be
dropping another diss track aimed at
Pusha T for Kanye West's sake Drake's
producer jay printz revealed on sway in
the morning that he called the hotline
bling' rapper to end his few to push a
tee after pusher dropped his own
scathing diss track the story of added
on well Jay Prince says an unreleased
song and response to push it was so bad
it could have ruined Kanye's career
after even speaking with Kanye yeah I
may even cause spoke with the brother
and he didn't want this you know what I
mean and I saw this corn in a place that
I feel would have ended his career your
trick would have put out the song that
you had and definitely would have hurt
families and you know what I mean and we
not we not in it for that you know the
meanness it's not great character I mean
you know we're not in business to toot
our brother Pelham and now you know to
that extent I'm wondering since it was
made if there's a chance that could
eventually leak no no no I don't think
it would leak because uh you know he
gave his word you know and me knowing
Drake like I know him you know he had
the word what kind of stuff that he said
either way Kanye tweeted just last week
that Lions were crossing this and it's
no good for anyone so maybe we've
reached the end of this long-standing
feud at least on records it sounds like
meanwhile Kanye's better half Kim
Kardashian is celebrating a huge victory
of her own president Trump granted
clemency to inmate Alice Marie Johnson
following his meeting with Kim so it
looks like her latest wish for positive
change is starting to come true we have
bats touring so much more on e t
online.com i'll see you guys tomorrow
because Beyonce and jay-z just kicked
off the tour and I here we see the twins
you